[Music]
Snow White and Rapunzel might be worlds
apart but they do have something in
common they are both raised by evil and
acceptable stepmothers if there's one
theory we can't shake it's the one that
ties Mother Gothel and queen grimhilde
together watch until the end to find out
if these two witches belong to the same
twisted soul new around here don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
give this video a big thumbs up now
let's find out if Mother Gothel and
queen grimhilde are one in the same stop
taking everything so seriously two peas
in a pod before we get started let's get
one thing out of the way Disney
animators didn't use the same techniques
to create Snow White and tangled so
knowing this it's only normal for these
film's characters to look different
however some similarities tie the two
characters together first of all both
Mother Gothel and queen grimhilde have
wide green eyes and heavy eyelids they
also have long thin eyebrows and rosy
cheeks if the color of the Evil Queen's
eyebrows are any indication of her hair
color
we'd be led to believe that she and
Mother Gothel both have dark brown hair
to top it all off both evil masterminds
also seem to have a similar style
despite the many centuries that occurred
during the two movies both villains are
wearing floor-length dresses with full
sleeves along with a red sash tied
around their waists but perhaps the most
convincing similarity of all is that
Mother Gothel seemed to be transforming
into the old version of the Evil Queen
after Rapunzel's hair was chopped off
are we the only ones who noticed this or
does this tidbit ring true in your gut
as well both their names mean mother if
there's one thing most Disney Princesses
have in common it's an evil stepmother
however when it comes to Snow White and
Rapunzel some might say that their
stepmothers are the worst of all
sure Cinderella's stepmom wasn't exactly
an angel but she never tried to murder
her stepdaughter or physically harm her
in any way Lady Tremaine had her
shortcomings but she had two daughters
of her own who she truly cared about
proving that she was capable
of loving when you put Mother Gothel and
queen grimhilde the scope you'll see
that they never had any true born
children of their own
but somehow their names translate to
mother according to a german dictionary
Gothel is a dialect for the word
godmother and when taking a look at the
meaning behind the name grim Hilde we
find that it translates to mother of
Gudrun if there's one thing that
confuses us it's that both these
characters felt the need to give
themselves as a motherly name when they
couldn't care less about motherhood
could it be that they chose fake names
to trick the public into thinking they
were good people that's four digit uno
and for us to find out in a disguise so
complete no one will ever suspect the
Evil Queen fell off a cliff all the evil
queen ever wanted was to be the most
beautiful woman who ever lived now is
that really too much to ask for instead
of realizing that real beauty is found
within queen grimhilde focused all of
her energy on her appearance and by the
end of Snow White it was hard to believe
that she had ever been anything but ugly
after scheming to end Snow White's life
the Evil Queen found herself at a loss
instead of hiring others to fulfill her
task she decided to poison her
stepdaughter herself this proved to be a
bad idea as she placed herself in the
same spot as the Seven Dwarves and they
intended on capturing her and bringing
her to justice after chasing the old
woman through the forest they found
themselves seconds away from being
crushed by a large boulder but
thankfully Mother Nature had something
else in mind
lightning struck at her feet causing her
to fall backward off a cliff and
unfortunately for her the giant boulders
followed suit while we never saw the
Evil Queen perish her death is
insinuated but still if there's one
thing movies have taught us it's that a
death isn't justified unless you see the
body so with this in mind Disney fans
have concluded that it's impossible to
confirm her passing which only adds fuel
to the theory that queen grimhilde and
Mother Gothel
are one in the
same they both have the same dagger
every villain has their weapon of choice
and since Disney isn't one to lack
imagination these weapons tend to be
very different from one another in Snow
White
queen grimhilde Huntsman to carve out
her stepdaughters heart she hands him a
dagger in a box and instructs him to
place the young princess's heart inside
of it before bringing it back to her
after chasing Snow White's into the
forest the Huntsman is smitten by her
beauty and decides to quit while he's
ahead
however returning with an empty box
would put his life at stake so as any
sensible Huntsman would do he places a
pig's heart inside of the box instead
the shiny long and terrifying dagger is
handed back to the Evil Queen and we
don't see it resurface for many decades
since it's common for Disney villains to
have weapons of their own if most of us
didn't think twice about mother Gotham's
dagger however once tipped off it became
clear that the daggers bore a striking
resemblance Mother Gothel uses her
dagger to harm Eugene and nearly
succeeds in ending his life luckily for
him Rapunzel's tears were just as
powerful as her long golden locks both
stories take place in Germany Disney
movies take place in a magical land that
we do not have access to
however Walt Disney isn't the one who
came up with his movies plots instead
Walt Disney Productions drew inspiration
through the Brothers Grimm folktales
most of which were too dark and terrible
to recite to children to bring these
stories to life Disney revamped the old
tales making them more kid-friendly
however some Horrors were too juicy to
omit when taking a deeper look at the
Snow White and Rapunzel fairy tales we
noticed something strange
both these fables take place in Germany
this information added fuel to the
Mother Gothel
queen grimhilde conspiracy making it
even more believable although Disney's
version of Rapunzel's story takes place
in the make-believe kingdom of Corona we
can't deny that its roots are firmly
planted in Germany so knowing this it's
totally possible that the Evil Queen
escaped her death and kept a low profile
until she was strong enough to
sanu if you're having a hard time
believing that this theory is correct
watch until the ends and be rewarded
with the biggest easter egg of all and
trust us when we say that'll appease
every ounce of your skepticism the time
gap we know what you're thinking how can
Mother Gothel be queen grimhilde
with their stories take place over three
hundred years apart well you're not
wrong but that doesn't mean that the
theory will get debunked so easily so
while it's true that Snow White took
place in the late 1500s and that
Rapunzel wasn't born until the early
1800s there's still a possibility that
the Evil Queen managed to cheat death
for centuries at a time as many of you
know
queen grimhilde wasn't exactly the
youngest girl on the block in fact some
people believed that she was already an
old and wicked woman by the time she
married Snow White's father and as we
clearly saw in Tangled mother Gothel was
as old as a pile of dust in fact as soon
as the flowers powers were destroyed the
evil stepmother began transforming into
an ancient entity her transformation was
so monstrous that her skin started to
flake away until it was nothing more
than a she's this scene proves that
Mother Gothel wasn't an old woman but an
ancient one one who most probably lived
for hundreds of years different movies
same actors well there are some notable
differences between the tingled and Snow
White plots both these stories are
filled with similar characters snow I
grew up with her darling father however
their happiness ran dry once he married
queen grimhilde
forced to continue without him Snow
White was placed under her stepmothers
care which proved to be dangerously
toxic on the other hand Rapunzel was
kidnapped at birth and made to share a
roof with a manipulative and skilled
liar despite their different storylines
one thing remains the same two innocent
girls are travelling through a forest in
an attempt to gain their freedom and of
course their mothers are doing
everything in their power to hide them
from the world while queen grimhilde
wants to murder her stepdaughter to
become the fairest of them all mother
Gothel tends to use Rapunzel to remain
the most beautiful version of herself
both these
we are tailored around the beauty and
captivity which ties their villains
together with ease while Snow White's
stumbles upon a small house filled with
dwarves
Rapunzel comes upon a tavern filled with
a sketchy men but alas both protagonists
put their prejudice aside and befriend
the unexpected death by falling despite
being adored by children Disney movies
are based on very mature themes since
making them 100% PG is impossible some
intense scenes made it all the way to
the drawing board and Beyond
at the end of Snow White's the Evil
Queen is chased to the top of a mountain
where she soon plummets to her death or
so were led to believe
oddly enough Mother Gothel suffers the
same fate when she tumbles out of the
tower window
unlike queen grimhilde though we clearly
see Mother Gothel dissolve in a cloud of
smoke as her body hits the ground so is
it a coincidence that both these evil
stepmothers perished the exact same way
or could it be that history is repeating
itself to get rid of an ancient entity
who's been preying on young women for
far too long perhaps one of the biggest
clues tying these two villains together
is the way their bodies begin to age as
they near their end when Mother Gothel
spell is broken she begins to revert to
her old self which is basically
identical to the old woman queen
grimhilde transforms into in Snow White
it's almost as if Disney creators wanted
us to make the connection between these
two conniving women powers and abilities
both queen grimhilde and mother Gothel
are obsessed with being young and
beautiful however their need for beauty
ends up costing them a lot more than
they can afford as many of you know the
Evil Queen has many magical skills and
she's not afraid to use them so long as
she gets what she wants
she uses dark magic spells and alchemy
whenever she needs an upper hand and
nine times out of ten her victims are no
match for her the Evil Queen is highly
intelligent and manipulative so does
this remind you of anyone while Mother
Gothel doesn't have access to potions
and spell books this could be because
she was unable to retrieve her stash
from Snow White's castle after falling
off the cliff
so in
Stud she harvested magical flowers to
achieve a state of youth funny enough
both Gothel and grimm hilde are
nicknamed the which even though Gothel
is hardly ever seen doing spells
thankfully these wretched villains are
no match for Disney's pure hearted
heroines to shroud my crown the black of
night the red apple so we promise to put
your skepticism to rest and we're ready
to deliver the final piece of the puzzle
at first Eugene couldn't have cared less
about Rapunzel but soon he realized that
she was the only person he could truly
be himself with so knowing this you can
imagine how distraught the fugitive was
when he realized that Rapunzel had been
kidnapped and brought back to her
isolated tower without skipping a beat
Eugene retraced his steps and found
Rapunzel's home once more determined to
rescue the princess from the evil woman
who claimed to be her mother
Eugene's heroic moment was short-lived
however as mother Gotham's dagger soon
pierced him so what makes us believe
that Mother Gothel is indeed
queen grimhilde the fact that Goethals
stab wound left the imprint of an apple
on the wall directly above Eugene's head
this little easter egg confirms our
suspicions proving that Rapunzel's
captor is in fact the putrid Evil Queen
from Snow White
after all the poison apple is her most
prominent trademark so have we convinced
you that these two villains are the same
person let us know your verdict in the
comments below and that's it for our
video thanks for watching and see you
next time on the things
[Music]